hello I'm a nostalgia critic I remember
so you don't have to it's not always
easy being a critic yeah but sometimes
it can be annoying and when I say that I
don't mean like watching a horrible
horrible movie no no I mean watching an
incredibly boring movie and I mean
boring
case in point let's take a look at wires
if I told you this was about a little
boy who taped the journey to a fantasy
of kangaroos no Marshall arts you say
that sounds like shit but at least it
would keep my attention right wrong this
movie is beyond on entertaining is just
a painted tip I'd rather watch paint dry
while keeping an eye on grass growing
while watching a TV show with mr. t Hulk
Hogan and Bruce Campbell filing their
taxes it is that boring so what makes
this an unbelievable dolphin well pull
up a pillow and let's find out so let's
start out with a very vague back story
about how the age of wire seems to be
bathing in the time of crisis is there
someone with the courage to step forward
but I fear for him as I fear for us okay
this isn't lead to man an action-packed
adventure that promises lots of
excitement well it is the furniture
coolie suspense
my modeling fantasy and Cody confines of
middle-class suburbia
so we come across a kid named Ryan
reading probably the worst wrong Thomas
book in the history of comic books and
guess all the heroes are mute too
because there isn't one single word
bubble on any of those pages
sheesh bubbling chorusing I say it's an
insult the comic readers everywhere now
let me tell you why so we go from
reading comic on the John to the sibling
of shrimp in a stir-fry
all right even I am chef doesn't show up
as much guy just freaking relax do you
really need to jump kick the bosses
I mean is it absolutely necessary we're
Chef Ramsay when you need oh you don't
get so I guess
Ryan is friends with the chef don't
really know how that happens but okay
as the chef tells them about the
mystical brouhaha about being a master
of something let go of your limitations
Ryan imagine a world beyond anything
you've ever seen
ah look I just ordered a compound
chicken can you get it for me already
oh well defended by a great warrior just
I'm kind of hungry no guns no lasers no
more thing probably game called to use
the forces of nature as a weapon you're
not getting a 10
okay now we're a sports movie hell's
going on here do you pick a friggin
scenario oh so he's a waterboy on a
football team because he has a limp leg
that doesn't allow him to play well but
that doesn't stop him from giving some
helpful advice it kotoba in google glad
you have a clear path to the endzone
like you won the water juice one hopeful
but attuned as a football player tasted
advice and wins the game
okay we officially entered into a
different manner I don't know the county
director if you came through DX then we
got me into the strip but this is the
same self Eastern out
laughter that ending to another film
Ryan points out I'll be help the
football player so the top guy tries to
find a nineteen way to return the favor
you want to hang out with a snack yeah
sure
cool we'll be around the horn a ton of
about eight o'clock great well Peter all
right you'll make every kid's favorite
hotspot Chinese kitchen where he gets in
trouble misunderstanding what was it
someone was yelling ah ah hey I need you
later
hurry he killed who bad he's any clearly
Chancellor hold anything back
should I not handle your mouth look I'm
sorry okay oh yeah tell you that
[Music]
okay this guy should be on special
forces or something what the hell is he
doing in a damn cage what's this
it's a cocoon house on my way home from
school it's not lying on the ground just
sitting there yeah don't you need to
come through or something but then all
of a sudden Danny came into the ground
Wow kitchen is on fire stop telling that
kid no stop it Darian ha ha ha
I was lucky once never thought that was
good enough always wanted to be like
someone else this is Tom you mean Dao
the word that spell like Alva pronounced
like now except by people that know
absolutely nothing about Chinese it is
so they mean it's a location the
football player was talking about as
they go into the tunnel of the place I'm
sort of I thought they're going to
consciously by the way who just randomly
raised their flashlights wait so they
get this big super where I guess they
partake in this sort of rite of passage
or something kid needs to cross the beam
and get to the other side of spray-paint
you're moving like a baby what just get
down and crawl long before you
physically disabled or something this is
probably bad idea come on you're a plot
device
no I killed a ten-year-old they're
totally gonna drop me from the team for
this so for some reason he wakes up in
Yoda's bathroom where it seems some
mythical sewer magically transported
into another world now he's in Fern
Gully ah so he looks around the
whimsical world when he suddenly comes
across a very interesting looking
character excuse me can you tell me how
to get to the set of Tank Girl what I
didn't think it was that man in the
movie so well screaming at things
running away he does something very
interesting yeah did you forget you were
flushed down the toilet into a
supernatural world just over my neck by
that little guy from twin P but then it
suddenly saved by Emily we're not safe
here
meanwhile on the set of dune we see our
villain named Komodo I brought you this
from a boy newcomer you come on a
monarch is not pleased
general Grillo I ask you this what's the
point of power
if you don't views people I'm trying to
do every Johnny Depp football is I've
ever seen my lord it's the symbol of tau
oh really
the symbol of tau boy how dare you you
must be a very caring person to kiss
pensa teeth press a information so right
of his new friend talk about where he is
who are you we're in life I'm Olivia
you're in town oh god damn it who said
if it was ever return to town oh I
changed everything when he came to talk
about you know if your fictional just
just call it and all you want
so they arrived at their town which kind
of look like the Narnian to the and
lands giving money
Ewoks and their leader comes forward to
give them some we cannot let our fears
defeat us nothing wrong we have hope a
newcomer has arrived he's too smart to
be hide you ha ha
houston we have a problem and that's my
final answer because my heart will
always go on right after I achieve it
Alicia said you have brought the
manuscript
it is important newcomer
the name is Ryan's Jeffers yes truly
boys and / - please the master Chun
showed him the Teenage Mutant Ninja
marsupial that he disgraced their
character traits that will not really be
exerted outside of the factory just with
this is why virtue of order the
stability of food is also an alcoholic
she tried virtual high wisdom often
playful and clouded homosexual action
the virtue of loyalty in her spare time
she writes for Business Week magazine it
means little of the price is great you
first you upright chakras she used open
for Jimi Hendrix talk how to work with
here so while admiring these Joel camel
Easter Bunny
Chung s Brian the important question he
is a newcomer and he has brought
something important to us now Ryan
Jeffers may we see the manuscript wait a
min why did you wait until night asking
that question it was right there you
started to break it off I mean what the
hell happened in between those scenes
and he has brought something important
to us ah ten time
none knows where it is
if the newcomer with taste at the river
it would have been John dr. Clough is
right it was probably young so we can't
seem to be with them range what are you
thinking about oh I wonder for my mom
and dad are worried about me I wish I'd
known my mother and father we digestor
my brother and I were born
Master Chun looked after us one boring
backstory later she tastes as simple in
the morning where all these stanzas
stand but after the warrant out started
it was just riveting all this was built
in honor of the rules during the old
order they revered by every but after
the war encountered why didn't leave
everyone he killed someone in the battle
so what it was a battle people died it
was a life cycle
somebody will understand understand what
you remind me of my brother he's always
kidding kunis wait a minute Brian so the
bad guys tried to kidnap Brian when they
were approached by John the worry of
virtue who broke his vow by killing
something so he doesn't find anything
yes he doesn't find anymore all these
flips kicks and punches he's drawing
right now yeah he doesn't do any of that
shame because it looks like he's really
eunuch but no he broke his vow man would
never just turn his back in a little
second because its honor means too much
by the way what's with the blurry vision
the secret's out winning your opponent
cutting praise
I love destroy you along with the other
power ranger Liang News swore he would
never fight again fighting again as the
other mutilated Ron Perlman's welcome to
no wait you can't just pass over that
scene I mean what is that like a tard an
alarm clock isn't a crowing rooster
who's Balder to be crushed
what'll be what so after math we get
another theme with King's fire but if
the manuscript can harm us why don't we
just destroy it it cannot be destroyed
you can be destroyed your armies can be
destroyed but it Turner's be destroyed I
have no idea what I'm doing directions
don't give me direction do it
this purple shooting very much my lord
then you are dismissed
I have no idea why we're following you
sir so after that we get another scene
of our hero chips sitting down and
talking God isn't this and I made a
pledge to protect these people we can't
leave them to insolence pledge domestic
trouble oh and just to make the scene
even cheaper
they run the footage of you Lisa walking
backwards
really you couldn't just remember to
tell the actress to turn around and walk
down the stairs you have to shoot it in
Reverse we're birthing two filaments one
the cheapest moves you can do nice
really really cheap
one for one
meanwhile at the home of the honey nut
cheerios B we see that Lydia is a
trainer who's fine to betray her fellow
friends
cutest it was alive I guess no one can
say that without putting on so after
playing duck duck goose here we return
back to Ryan who starts talking to the
mini-me version of Andy Serkis who says
he has the manuscript hey kid kid well
no one's gonna find it but me but I'll
take you there
what does any wonderful is now
incredibly boring business huh let's
take you forever
he's captured again gee I sure hope
there's someone to rescue him making
this moment in time a pointless and the
boredom consulter Komodos lies have
blinded your vision you know I don't
think that blurry vision is going to
make two people talking see more
exciting it's departing so we come to
the wires as they claim to sneak into
Komodos palace to get the book no it's
too easy what are you doing here oh are
you really back surprise yum cha like it
was alive
the proposed thank you for hanging
around here inside just said that like
we at the world of power have no
cinematix shame you can't mine invited
into my I don't move the schwa and I'll
enjoy I bring what is I love you shout
so tries to drop them in a mechanical
flanker encounter but they managed to
escape so you think this would mean the
action is honor right no we still have
more scenes of Top Cow philosophy what
matters is not what you're going there
but ignore you know what strap to give
young everyone quick USANA Chicago
really reconsider the Royal John knows
what promoters was negative only look
Amano finally rise to turn up the heat
what is this guy's problem
he just iced up on ecstasy are you even
intimidated by a guy's hilarious if I
could get sillier and sillier as the
movie goes off
we killed master Chun as the rest of the
village is under attack
Ryan is kidnapped again and is taken to
the lava-lamp ours Ryan I wanted to tell
you you're on his side
you're a traitor no listen to me Ryan
let me explain it was our life oh my god
please looking for me this guy is too
much you got a big booty I know your
sorrow I know your loneliness
I lost my bipolar depression control I
am proud to yoga school no one will ever
laugh at you again I promise you that
ah yeah if this guy is telling you he
can make nobody laugh at you I win
trusted take me to ball one chain and
then in one of the oddest moments and
trust me that's saying a lot
rights is one of the most desired things
in a kids movie yeah shit happens
shit happens shit dude guys
what's with the potty mouth like three
more though then you get a pg-13 you're
going to fuck can you
[Music]
so Ryan gets away with his killed and
Komodo keeps monkey
I love this guy
why doesn't he have his own Saturday
morning cartoon show so Ryan escapes an
entire army of soldiers and Komodo
follows into the captured village so he
inspires the rest of the Fishlips
donkeys to whip out their stale macaroni
and cheese swords and battle Komodo for
the final time you've come uninvited
into our like spring Komodo this is our
water come out Hey aah
all right it's official this guy is one
of the missing moons
turned up a little hesitant all right oh
no no no no no there's not a brittle it
in the world to handle final me it's
like Mortal Kombat makes for the petting
zoo how is this supposed to be taken
seriously
just to make it even more annoying the
whole entire climax is shot in the damn
blurry video I am dead serious we
finally get some good action and we
can't make any of that
it's like watching Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon while you're doing this
whatever point well the kid starts to
sum up my reaction to the movie he
finally figured out how to read the book
and defeat Komodo it turns out the wires
had to combine two magic medallions to
get the medallion what what would force
combine I am Captain Planet
Ryan sacrificed himself to save us
Komodo expended his energy eh whatever
just get to the part where they send
them home
are you interrupts different
oh no the movies starting over again ah
so this time around he doesn't cross the
beam and it's going to go home your God
I've never been more relieved to see
boring suburbia
so Ryan goes home kisses his mother
goodnight and then takes another look at
the cocoon from earlier huh guess they
forgot to write this into the story he
brought 20 year buzz down you mean now
your dumb shirt the less Warriors
important finding work and I have to
admit for a movie about martial arts
kangaroos that battled over actor in
black mascara I'm pretty underwhelmed
it's just boring and every comprehension
of the word the kangaroo says no
character a kid is not interesting
philosophy is honed in world is
unimaginative only thing I kind of like
in this movie invest beer don't build
that's just because he's so over the top
man let's be fair this guy has done a
lot of good serious work like a heart
attack so I really printed this marching
band right there but hey at least it was
entertaining which is what I can say for
the rest of this stupid film my advice
if you really want to see this film just
watch kangaroo jack and Enter the Dragon
both at the same time while doing this
that Amit's would be more entertaining
I'm gonna sound Critic I remember it so
you don't have to
[Music]
it was a life